young John Lewis you're so full of
passion in your lifetime you would be
arrested 45 times in your mission to
help redeem the soul of America in 1956
when you were only 16 years old you'll
and some of your brothers and sisters
their first cousins went down to the
puppet library trying to get library
cards trying to check out some books and
you were told by the librarian that the
library wieck's only not for colors I
said to you no well you see something
that is not right not fair not just you
have a moral obligation to continue to
speak up to speak out
you became so inspired dr. King and Rosa
Parks that you got involved in the civil
rights movement something to church you
and suggested that you write a letter to
dr. King you didn't tell your teachers
you don't tell your mother and your
father dr. King broke through back and
invited you to come over that night in
the meantime you have been a mitad to
law school in Nashville Tennessee and it
was there that you got involved in it
City and you'll be sitting there and
orderly peaceful nonviolent fashion and
someone will cut off your speed on you
I'll put it like just look where it are
down your back pull hot water hot coffee
hot chocolate on you
[Music]
you got arrested the first time and you
feel so free you felt liberated you felt
like you had crossed over you probably
would never believe it but the boy from
Troy as dr. King used to call you will
become the embodiment of non-violence in
America two years as you speak at the
march on Washington you will see to face
the death lead in the March of voting
across the Edmund Pettus Bridge in Selma
a marching today from Selma to
Montgomery your margin to our state
capitol to dramatize to our nation into
the world our determination to win first
by citizenship
[Music]
[Applause]
beating on the bridge left money what's
up - look one two diamond but you will
make it you would live to see your
mother and father
yes they're fresh folks the change we
need doesn't come from Washington change
comes to Washington
you'll also live to see this segregated
nation you live in it's in an
african-american president and his
family to the White House and guess what
guess what
young John that's some divine providence
as it is to send a message down through
the ages that man will be nominated on
the 45th anniversary of the march on
Washington
and all of those signs that you so as a
little child that said white men colored
men white women colored women those
sighs are gone and the only places you
will see those signs today will be in a
book in a museum or video John thank you
for going to the library with your
brother's your sisters and cousin you
would do not elaborate on sad
but one day you've been elected to the
Congress you wrote a book called walking
with the wind in the same library
invited you to come back full book
signing for blacks or white citizen
showed up and after the book signing
they gave you a library card and believe
as dr. King and a filler Randolph and
others taught you that we want people
and it doesn't matter what wheel black
or white Latino Asian American or Native
earth
it may be our foremothers and our
forefathers all came here in different
ships we all in the same
John you understood the words of dr.
King when you said we must learn to live
together as brothers and sisters if not
we were perish as fool's
[Music]
you